as a general rule we tend to favor
equality over quantity
but there's something to be said for
quantity
[Music]
hey folks it's been a hot minute since I
did a video talking broadly about
lgbtqia plus representation in film and
television and I think I want to come
back and do that again
so part of the reason I haven't tackled
this topic in a while is by and large I
usually am either dealing with super
specific incidences
usually because somebody screwed up or
I'm talking broad overarching Trends
tropes and lending a perspective to the
general concept and there's only so many
broad Strokes to be made before you need
to get a bit more granular than that and
as I said I tend not to unless I've got
some really specific to say
so I want to try and offer
what will seem on its face
are really
foolishly simplistic answer to the
question of
how do we get better lgbtqia plus
representation
have more of it
I told you it sounds foolishly simple
and reductive and like what that's it
well good
no that's not it but also
yeah kinda
see
here's the thing
the less you have of representation of
any kind be it lgbtqi plus people be it
disabled people be it fat people be it
people of color indigenous people
whatever it might be
the fewer instances you have the more
pressure gets put on each instance
the
um let's go with punditary left those of
us who are left leaning and speak on
media
we're notoriously nitpicky
and for every instance of quote unquote
good representation you might find even
if it is largely praised by people like
me in the position that I am in
you're gonna find at least a couple of
outliers picking apart something wrong
with it and I don't just mean people
looking to stir up nonsense and I'm
definitely not talking about the
anti-woke crowd who just slam all of it
I'm talking about people from within
this community who go
okay yeah but and the thing is they're
usually right
you can't have a character that lands
with everybody that appeals to everybody
that speaks to the experience of
everybody that takes everything into
account and is then also successful as a
character I mean you just can't
but you shouldn't have to
and sometimes I really get the feeling
because I I get the frustration
from certain creators
um performers writers whatever it may be
I sense a certain frustration when they
get criticism from the community they're
depicting especially if they themselves
are a member of that Community
oftentimes they will write a character
that is representative of their own
experience and then get told well that's
problematic because of X Y and Z and
those criticisms might be fair but that
shouldn't be taken as a negation of
somebody's own experience being placed
into a character but I get that
frustration I do
but the reason everything gets frankly
over examined
the reason why the most mainstream
exposure that lgbtqia plus characters
get gets over scrutinized by everybody
especially folks like me from within the
community
is because there isn't enough of it
think of it like a bed of nails if you
don't know the principle by which you
are able to lay down on a bed of nails
I'll explain it it's a distribution of
pressure
because when your body weight is
distributed across hundreds if not
thousands of individual points while any
single one of those points is sharp
enough to do some significant damage to
your body you distribute the weight you
distribute the pressure
and you are fine
I've Lane on a bed of nails actually
it's not comfortable enough to sleep on
but it's fine
however
the fewer and fewer Nails you have the
more pressure gets put on each
individual nail on each individual
instance of representation and suddenly
all the pressure is on a handful of
things
I actually talked about this broad
concept years ago
I don't think I'd even come out yet on
this channel I definitely wasn't
presenting like this I think at all
definitely not on a regular basis when I
talked about the reception to Wonder
Woman and how there was a really odd
kind of internal struggle going in going
on between people I think largely agreed
in the broad Strokes about what they do
and don't like about Cinema and what
they would or wouldn't like to see about
representation of women as superheroes
but what some of the people who I knew
found is that they kind of got
shamed might be the wrong word but when
they came with criticisms for Wonder
Woman they they felt like they were kind
of getting don't bring that up let us
have this kind of a feel just because
something about the movie or the
character didn't fully work for them
because there was the sense of this is
the only one we have don't tear it down
and that felt necessary to some people
to defend Wonder Woman as a film and as
a character to that extent because
we hadn't had a female-led superhero
movie since I was either Catwoman or
Elektra was the last one prior to that
for major mainstream release
so yeah there was frankly more pressure
than should be on any one film uh as a
result of that Gap and of superheroes
being huge and if this failed
there was a fear that we're not going to
get any more
but of course
we are going to over analyze we are
going to pick it apart because you can't
appeal to everybody with a single
character
but that's why you do more
now I could say somewhat facetiously I
mean it's not like you hear people
complaining about the depictions of
white CIS heterosexual men
except you do but that's from a crowd
that I choose not to deal with as much
as I can get away with basically the
anti-world crowd the ones who just
complain about any diversity whatsoever
and also anytime a CIS white hat male is
not the lead and if they can spot one in
the movie who is not idealized they will
claim that the movie is making fools of
men
I'm not dealing with this I'm
acknowledging that they exist but the
thing is when we actually talk about
moviegoers not people who have made
literal careers out of stoking outrage
and have become what I refer to as
outrage merchants
setting those people aside for a minute
because again I ain't dealing with them
today by and large
a film that depicts a CIS white
heterosexual able-bodied guy
in a bad way as a coward as a villain as
a fool whatever it may be
even if
an audience member who matches all those
descriptors doesn't like it you know
what
he's got literally hundreds of other
things to watch that will have
characters that match those same
descriptors and that are done completely
differently
not so much
with minorities
and this is Again by no means true of
only the lgbtqia plus Community but that
is the perspective I come at this from
being white able-bodied so you know I
try not to talk out of turn with other
issues so I'm speaking of this through
the lens of lgbtqi plus representation
but keep in mind it does absolutely
apply other places I'm just you know
staying in my wheelhouse
I don't want to money my points by
saying something foolish because I I
just tried to come at it from an angle
that I don't understand as well
you know sometimes taking your in your
lane isn't about like ah instead of
things you don't understand it's just
about
if that's not your main focus is being
sure that you handle that specific
aspect respectfully maybe just stick to
what you do know that's what I'm doing
here
so coming back to my original point just
have more
I know it's an odd thing to hear
basically a quantity over quality
argument but the thing is
the more quantity there is
the less Perfection will be demanded of
every individual instance
basically
if you want people like me off your back
for the way that you depict lgbtqia plus
characters in your films in your TV
shows Etc
create a world where if I don't like one
I can turn around and there's another
option
that's it
the reason so much scrutiny is put on
these things is because lack of options
at least in the mainstream and I do want
to emphasize that is where I'm coming at
this from you can certainly point to
queer Focus Media and some of it is
great but by and large it's Indie it's
niche it's small scale and
in a world where streaming services
especially that used to be a place where
a smaller more Niche idea could find a
home are now getting purged on a regular
basis or canceled after only one or two
seasons
yeah that isn't going to fully cut it in
terms of giving us
a sense of being able to see ourselves
on the screen
and another reason that I focus on
mainstream stuff is
call me basic if you like I enjoy
mainstream stuff
like I talk about
you know all these mainstream massive
popular franchises because that's what I
actually enjoy
I remember when I first started talking
about this a lot of people would bring
up you know all these indie films that
like I should be watching or I should be
buoying or I should be you know talking
about and bolstering and
I'm not saying I don't want to do that
but the thing is by and large those
things are small scale small budget
usually dramas
I like action I like science fiction I
like fantasy those things require
budgets they require mainstream support
that's where I go that's where I would
like to be able to see myself and I
would also point out that relegating all
of the lgbtqia plus content into a
special corner for the niche content the
queer content for the queer people that
doesn't really help either because
representation doesn't just matter in
terms of us being able to see ourselves
but also you know
normalizing us
just having us exist
I've talked elsewhere in other videos
some of them years old I actually should
go back and see if any of those are
worth redoing from Strat from scratch I
don't know how much I stand by some of
the things I said before I don't think I
I stepped in it too badly but you know
times change I get older and presumably
wise
why I don't know I should recheck some
of those but anyway I have talked
uh in other places about a lot of the
specifics you know the ins and outs of
of certain aspects and certain things
that uh are to be kept in mind with
representation but just
one of the things that needs to be there
is that we're just treated as normal you
don't always have to make our being
queer in some manner as the central
point of a character it can be a small
part of a character that doesn't mean
like a single kiss that you can cut for
the foreign market that stuff's getting
old I've defended it in the past and the
basically on the it's better than
nothing basis and honestly I think at
the time I felt that pretty sincerely
I'm over it
like either do it or back off and quit
trying but I say that but at the same
time more
you can look at things like glad which
does every year it's report on the uh
depictions of and the representation of
lgbtqi plus characters in network
television in streaming and in cable
and they have uh their 2021 2022 one out
and I was taking a look at their most
recent one and then I compared it to the
last few years now things did get better
over time you go back to when they first
started tracking we were looking at
representation and they only measure
featured or recurring characters meaning
like part of the main cast or appear
more than one so like one off oh here's
my gay friend we'll never see again they
don't count that but in terms of what
they saw when they first started
tracking this it was like one percent of
characters
and then for a while it hovered around
four to six percent and for the last
four or five years it has bounced around
between
around nine percent to a high of almost
12. but it's kind of gone up and down
but in that range but it's kind of
stagnated for a while now granted that
measures television not film but it's a
decent metric overall partially because
television because there's just more of
it
there's more shows there's more casts
there's more characters uh it's honestly
usually a little bit ahead of TV I've
mentioned that before elsewhere as well
and things have kind of stayed still for
a while and I will be the first to admit
things are better than they used to be
it used to be you know you could find
one two two four maybe shows with a
regular gay character and people would
point to things like Will and Grace and
later on Modern Family and things like
that and go look look at all this
progress I'm like okay that's one
depiction
that's great
um but like if you're thinking that's
going to satisfy this entire diverse
Community I mean you you're wrong
and not because we're unpleasable
because you can't satisfy a diverse
group of people with only one character
that's why for as much as some of them
complain
cisgender heterosexual white able-bodied
men
if they don't like one thing they might
still throw a fit about it some of them
but they can find something else that
they like
they're always very quick to go okay
well that sucks but this is great
yeah because you you had another option
didn't you
we don't have that many we have more
than we used to
I would hate to see the
progress stagnate
now I have no doubt that some people
are going to complain to me about
percentages percentages of the
population first of all
measuring what percentage of the
population identifies as some form of
lgbtqia plus is actually very tricky in
the first place because it has to be
self-reported
because for many of us you don't know
where queer unless we tell you like you
can look at me
and yeah probably you can guess but
there's a lot out there who nobody knows
they are unless they say so so the fact
that self-reported means that whatever
percentage you are currently seeing when
you look up what percentage of the
population is lgbtqia Plus
that's inherently an undercount
because not everybody is out and not
everyone feels comfortable to say
so no matter what it is it's low
but even that low number
has been going up
because despite everything going on in
the world
overall
more of us feel safe saying hey
I exist
so if you want to
try and pitch a fit about well it's only
just small percentage of the population
it is a percentage of the population
that we are getting better at counting
and is growing
first of all
and secondly
you are not lacking for representation
we are
and if you find our our being present
threatening
that has nothing to do with us and
everything to do with you
'll notice I'm asking for more lgbtqia
plus characters I'm not asking for fewer
cisgender white hetero able-bodied men
I could but I'm not now there are way
too many people who treat everything as
a zero-sum game if we gain something
they must have lost something
I don't know how to break you of a
mindset like that I mean it's a very
ingrained capitalist mindset to be
honest because we are raised to fight
for limited resources such as money so
we tend to treat many things as if they
are limited as if somebody else gaining
means we either directly lost something
or that could have been our gain but
they took it instead
But ultimately
it actually is that simple
have enough of us appear
as characters
that when one of them sucks
we can shrug it off and go ah
that's okay I got this one over here and
that one and that one
get us to the point
where we don't have to care if there is
a bad piece of representation because we
know it's not the only thing out there
and honestly as I said over the last
decade or so the decade that I've been
doing this certainly
we're headed in the right direction
but it has stagnated in the last few
years don't stop
go further
go deeper
go harder
I
I'm sorry I should stop
thank you very much for listening to me
uh I hope you don't regret doing so
as I said I haven't done one of these in
a while uh I may be slightly Rusty
in any case whatever your thoughts are
in any of this drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a patreon
pays the bills allows me to do this has
my living there's links to other things
in the description that you can help me
out with
um but don't worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council and I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
shout out to the patrons who helped make
this possible in particular I want to
thank Robin Moore Zubin fulla goddess
Elida to rock the thing that goes joint
in the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen auntie
kate808 Becky Sparks pranabilox the
poodle Robin Powell t love Tracy scravid
angry Casper Dave Hall and Rosalind
Bennett there's being able to hear me
try and pronounce your name plus a whole
bunch of other rewards in the patreon
you can check out the tears but um
if you're already on the list thank you
so much
foreign
[Music]